- Bonjour, Mme Tardif.
Bienvenue.
- Un bureau médical
comme n'importe quel autre.
Mais ici, il y a une différence
majeure.
- Respirez fort.
- Les patients comme
Sophie Tardif assument
la totalité des coûts
de leur consultation.
Et elle parcourt les 300 km pour
faire l'aller-retour entre Laval
et son domicile en Estrie.
SOPHIE TARDIF, patiente
- Parce qu'au CHU Fleurimont,
bien, j'avais un an d'attente
pour rencontrer un pneumologue
puis faire les tests du souffle.
- OK.
- C'est pour ça que j'ai cherché
au privé un pneumologue.
- Ici, elle a eu rendez-vous
en moins de deux semaines
en pneumologie. Une rapidité
qui a convaincu son pneumologue
de quitter le secteur public
en janvier.
Dr JAD HOBEIKA, pneumologue,
Groupe Médical Lacroix
- J'étais pas confortable
avec l'idée... avec la quantité
de patients qui attendaient
sur des listes d'attente.
Moi, ultimement, j'ai fini par
faire le saut en grande partie
pour cette accessibilité-là.
- En pneumologie,
27 000 requêtes sont en attente
au Québec. Et le délai moyen
avant d'obtenir une consultation
est de 322 jours. Un problème
qu'on retrouve dans plusieur
spécialités et qui amène
plusieurs médecins spécialistes
à quitter le secteur public.
178 sont maintenant passés
au privé : une hausse de 55 %
depuis cinq ans. L'accès
déficient au public alimente
la croissance du své.
- Donc, notre deuxième bloc
opératoire au Groupe Médical
Lacroix, celui de Laval ici,
est en fonction depuis mars.
- Lacroix médecine privée
fait de la chirurgie et offre
des consultations dans
dix spécialités. Le groupe
compte maintenant dix cliniq
et environ 90 médecins appuyés
par une centaine d'autres
professionnels.
JEAN-NICOLAS CHAGN
Groupe Médical Lacroix
- La croissance, c'est
exponentiel à chaque année.
La demande est là. Pour vous
donner uidées, on idées, on idét
à 150 000 visites par année
pour le Groupe Médical Lacroix
par année.
- L'expansion exige plus
d'espace et une diversification
des servts,ts,ts,ts,ts,ts,
par exemple en santé mentale.
- C'est Maryse Parkinson,
l'infirmticienne
spécialisée en santé mentale.
- Elle a quitté le public
pour le privé au printemps.
MARYSE PARKINSON, infirmière
praticienne, Groupe Lacroix
- C'est incroyable. Les gens
peuvent venir de Chibougameau,
Gatineau, Baie-Comenir
me consulter à cause que
l'attente est de huit mois
pour voir un psychiatre.
- Elle est déjà très occupée.
Faute de services
mentale, plusieurs sont prêts
à payer.
- Pour une évaluation initiale,
c'est entre 350 et 550,
et pour les suivis
- En médecine familiale aussi,
le nombre de médecins qui
quittent le public augmente,
comme la demande des patients
au privé. À Boucherville, en
Montérégie, on compte maintenant
quatre cliniques privées.
Peut-être parce qu'environ
le quart de la population
n'a pas de médecin de famille.
ÉMIE GERVAIS, omnipraticienne,
édical Lacroix
- J'ai certains patients
qui sont venus qui étaient
bénéficiaires de l'aide socialer
leur budget pour pouvoir
venir consulter, pour pouvoir
avoir des soins.- Plusieurs patt
parfois de payer après avoir
trop attendu.
- On voit des pathologies qui,
on se dit : mon Dieu, on est
Québec, en 2022. C'est un peu
drôle que ça se soit rendu
jusque-là parce que la personne
avait juste pas de médecin, là.
- Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Mo